[Music]
Blizzcon 2017 had a lot of new overwatch
announcements including a brand new
amusement park map Blizzard world and to
everyone's surprise a brand new hero
meet Moira the talent physicist who's
part scientists part anime part David
Bowie and gives just as much as she
takes now what I mean by that is that
she's a hybrid dps healer and possesses
a move set that requires you to deal
damage in order to heal overwatch has
been hurting for a good support hero for
a long time and thankfully Moira fills
that void of a decent healer with enough
utility to sometimes prop the team up on
their shoulders there are a lot of
little details with her so let's get
started shall we for primary and
secondary fire make up the ability known
as biotic grasp you'll be using these
two skills than most so you'll want to
make sure you understand the nuances of
using them their primary fire will
shower friendly targets in front of you
with a frothy yellow let's call it
healing juice it heals at a rate of 80
health per second as well as a small
heal over time afterwards bionic grasp
doesn't use ammo in the traditional
sense like Ana's rifle but instead uses
an energy bar that slowly refills after
use it'll provide about nine seconds
worth of non-stop healing and can heal
multiple targets at once making it
really good when your team is in a
cluster near a choke point but since
your energy recharge is very slowly
you'll want to alternate using it with
your secondary fire which will help
replenish it it looks similar to Life
Drain healing Moira as you deal damage
and will lock onto an enemy from 20
meters out
it may not track as well as
symmetrization cleaner you know you
shouldn't be jumping around too much but
the range of the beam is surprisingly
long and I suggest dealing damage from
the back lines as often as possible
biotic grasp maybe her bread and butter
skill but what makes Moira really
interesting are her bio tech orbs that
she can launch you'll be able to send
out floating balls similar to a
symmetric energy ball that will either
damage or heal nearby players depending
on what type of orb you choose initially
they travel quickly to their destination
but upon making contact with the player
friendly or otherwise they will slow
down significantly to get the job done
the orbs will also bounce off walls
adding another layer strategy when send
them towards people so if you see an
enemy hiding behind a corner or up a
stairwell you can lob in orb in their
direction and chase them away it's all
about how you use the geometry of the
maps in your favor and will stay in safe
behind cover Hanzo
eat your heart out and speaking of
staying safe you'll be glad to know that
moira has a great mobility option with
her fade taking a page out of both
Reapers and tracers books fade acts as a
quick - that makes more were
invulnerable to damage and healing and
causes her to disappear from sight for a
second from the opponent's perspective
it can be pretty disorienting to try and
find you after a fade so use it to
disengage from fights whenever you feel
threatened moira may be able to drain
life but with only 200 health points
she's still pretty squishy and since
fade is technically a - there are
opportunities for some clever movement
so to recap
Moira's got life train a teleport
bouncing death orbs what's left oh
that's right a giant beam that destroys
everything in their path okay well
that's not exactly true it heals as well
coalescence is more resulta mobility and
it's a doozy a massive beam will fire
out of her hand damaging foes and
healing allies within your crosshairs as
well as granting a small passive heal
and speed increase for yourself again
this ability excels in narrow hallways
or anywhere teams bunch up it can chase
people away from payloads cut them off
at capture point or simply push them
back at a choke however the helium
coalescence doesn't quite match the Zen
Yanis transcendence and you do still
need to aim at friendly targets so if
you're the only support class you'll
want to prioritize replenishing your
team's health over dealing damage
the overwatch community-wide healer and
Moira more than fills that role with
tools that will no doubt intrigue
support mains and damage dealers alike
I think she'll fit right into the
current meta just fine because of the
range on many of her attacks you'll want
to stay far back behind any tanks or
frontline damage dealers and mainly come
out to poke with your bionic grasp using
fade to escape any pressure and biotic
orbs to sneak in damage will keep your
punks guessing your position and
questioning in their own Moira's role as
a support plants are somewhere between
zenyatta and onna so if you've
gravitated more towards healers with
offensive utility you're bound to feel
right at home with her that's all I've
got for Moira I hope you found this
guide useful and don't forget to check
out our other guides for every other
overwatch hero the list just keeps on
growing so check back whenever the next
character hits and I'll see you guys in
the next video